في ذكرى النكبه الفلسطينيه دعوات ماليزيه
ضد التطبيع مع اسرائيل
فعلى مدى اكثر من اسبوع تنشط الاوساط
الطلابيه والاكاديميه والمجتمع المدني في
عموم البلاد خصوصا في جامعه الملايا
بالعاصمه كوالالمبور بما يزيد من الوعي
بقضيه الشعب الفلسطيني
في هذه المسيره يطالب الاساتذه بمقاطعه
اسرائيل ودعم حق اللاجئين الفلسطينيين في
العوده الى وطنهم الاصلي
في استراليا اعتقد ان كلمه نكبه عباره
ضخمه تختصر كارثه التي حلت بالشعب
الفلسطيني فقد تسببت بتشريد ثلثي الشعب
واحراق 600 قريه وبلده فلسطينيه يجب الا
ننسى هذه الاحداث وان نذكر بها سنويا ولا
نتركها تمر عابره لا تكاد تذكر في التاريخ
قاده وناشط مؤسسات فاعله طرقوا ابواب
هيئات دوليه في ذكرى النكبه يدعون الى
ضروره معاقبه اسرائيل وتمكين الشعب
الفلسطيني من حقه في الحريه
الحكومه الماليزيه تؤكد على ان التصدي
لسياسه الفصل العنصري محور اساسي في
سياستها الخارجيه وانه لا مجال للتطبيع مع
اسرائيل قبل نيل الشعب الفلسطيني حقوقه
المشروعه
تقف ماليزيا مثل باقي دول العالم لتنديد
بهذه الاعمال الوحشيه ولا يمكننا السماح
بمثل هذه الاعمال غير الانسانيه وهذا امر
واضح جدا واي قرار نتخذه هو جميع
اتصالاتنا بالمجتمع الدولي تصب في هدف
انهاء معاناه الشعب الفلسطيني
ساهمت حروب اسرائيل المتعاقبه على قطاع
غزه وانتهاكات قوات الاحتلال المستمره في
الضفه الغربيه بتعزيز مطالب الماليزيين
برحيل الاحتلال لم يكن للنكبه الفلسطينيه
ان تكون حاضره في اذهان الماليزيين لولا
هذه الانشطه والفعاليات وقد ساهمت وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي في زياده الوعي السياسي
ودفعت الحكومه الى اتخاذ مواقف اكثر وضوحا
في دعم قضيه فلسطين
سامر علاوي الجزيره